When you get to space, because you're in a zero-g environment,...
...some really funky things happen to your body.
I grew an inch.
Right now I'm 5'11, but in space, I was six foot tall.
On the ground, gravity compresses your spine.
It pulls you down, the force vector going down.
In space, without gravity pulling your spine down,...
...every vertebra has a chance to move up,...
...which gives you your extra inch of height.
For some people in space,...
...your intracranial pressure changes with pushes on your eyeball...
...and that changes its shape, therefore requiring you to wear glasses in space.
So, it affects your vision.
So, we keep different prescriptions of glasses on board...
...just in case someone's vision changes.
Any changes in our bodies and anything that happens in space,...
...it's worth it for the spirit of exploration.